[Applause]
you would not hit someone with an open
chair that is a huge no-no hi i'm wwe
superstar shelton benjamin you may know
me as the gold standard i'm a three-time
intercontinental champion united states
champion three-time tag team champion
three-time 24 7 champion today we're
going to be looking at wrestling scenes
and movies and i'll be judging just how
real they are
that was a good sequence where she
grabbed the headlock and run up the rope
into the uh headlock takeover like that
was actually
a really cool very realistic very
accurate you know little sequence of
action
i'm being nitpicky when she had her foot
on her neck usually a reference saying
get your foot off the neck and they will
start counting because when you start
counting if they get to five you know
you get dq'd so
and that's a that's a super small
nitpicky thing but
this is very good
great athleticism on the part of her
brother i think that was a little bit of
showboating he went to the top but i
don't know why
and believe it or not
that happens a lot in
in for us today but guys will do stuff
from the top rope and even i will go
why'd you do that why'd you go up there
no because it looked cool okay it ain't
about the size of the dog in the fight
it's about the size of the fight in the
dog and this dog is about to bite hard i
heard it 20 years ago those are like
lines you could get off a dixie cup
remember wrestling to me that's like 20
of what we do because it's storytelling
you have to you know learn how to talk
you know to learn how to carry yourself
so that stuff yes you want to practice
that all the time you want to practice
that whenever you can i started with
john cena and i remember asking them how
did you get so good
at what we call cutting promos and john
said i basically just sit at home all
day and talk to myself in the mirror and
that's a part of wrestling that i think
a lot of
aspiring wrestlers don't get they assume
mr moves it's never the move right i've
seen a million elbow drops but for some
reason when i see the macho man does it
it's something special it's the
personalities
that surround already move the moves are
actually secondary from the setting to
the moves to the energy this is
definitely a 10 out of 10 for me
[Applause]
in lucha style wrestling you do have the
ring full of guys super outlandish
characters doing some really unique
moves you would think it's like a battle
royal it's just a big game of king of
the mountain you got a lot of guys
moving at the same time a lot of moving
parts i didn't see a lot of bad stuff i
saw
things i would expect to see at a lucha
show the only thing that i really saw
that i wouldn't
like is
so many guys doing so much stuff in a
small space there's just not enough room
to safely bounce around like that
the moves themselves very good if you
ever watched like you see some amazing
things even things that i go wild i
didn't even know you could do that so
even when the guy has the guys in two
headlocks that was obviously rigged but
i feel like i've seen so much lucha
stuff that i go i have no idea how
they're doing that that doesn't actually
make me think that's impossible i feel
like they're guys that can actually pull
that off
[Applause]
outside interference that's totally
illegal you're not allowed to do it but
hey what the ref doesn't see
it's just that simple as long as the ref
doesn't see it you're okay and wnb if
the rest sees it you'll get dequeued and
i don't mean you'll get dequeued because
that's in the script i mean you'll get
dq because that's what the ref is
supposed to do if you are going to have
those kind of situations you gotta make
sure the ref isn't looking
[Applause]
he gave a perfect
tombstone
power driver in the end it was safe you
notice the guy's head didn't touch the
mat but the tombstone power driver this
is made famous by the undertaker from a
safety aspect
this would actually kill a man to
protect yourself the guy taking the move
would wrap his arms around the guy
giving his waist and the guy giving it
would not drive his face
into the floor mouth move they have a
name but when associated with certain
talent they name them after themselves
the tombstone pile driver is
specifically named because it's the
undertakers i would probably give that a
nine
we call it hitting the ropes basically
just running and bouncing off the ropes
there are two kinds of ropes there are
cable where there's actually a steel
cable with a rubber
casing around it and there's rope real
rope actually is very springy it's
actually cheaper to have
but for wwe we use real rope because
real rope you get the best results all
around it works great for catapulting
you off the ring and it's more comfy
so tag matches you have two or more
partners versus another team two or more
partners one guy stays on the outside
while the two in the ring they battle it
out and eventually the other guy
literally
tags out that's pretty realistic we'll
be on the ring we'll be reaching going
come on come on get to me and it's all
part of the storytelling to you know
help build drama i'm a three-time tag
team champion so i've done it quite a
few times and in a lot of cases it's a
good chance to catch a rest
[Applause]
there is absolutely bells in pro
wrestling start the match finish the
match after every match you'll see the
ref go
ring the bell you see a ref do that
that's the ring the bell it's over or
ring the bell it starts most people
aren't paying attention to the ref so
they don't catch that little thing but
there is an actual bell next to the ring
next to the announcers while it's very
entertaining i would have to give this a
pretty low score to five
i'm actually amazed at the fact that
this is
very
very accurate every move is pretty much
spot on and i guess it would be
considering you have hulk hogan given
the moves one of the biggest names in
pro wrestling history
[Music]
the only thing that i would say
wouldn't happen is the girls on the
apron while the match is going on
because that's a safety hazard
[Applause]
we don't actually
use chairs like that we actually use
just steel chairs wood tends to splinter
it's dangerous you get cut we just don't
use it i would not allow that in a match
i'm in you would not hit someone with an
open chair that is a huge no-no too many
bad things can happen there
he could have based a little better get
a little more height on that hip toss
stallone
could have positioned himself to get
thrown higher he muscled him over there
is an art to taking a beating
wow so stop if you if you look right
here that is a
example of what we call posting see
where uh his hands are he's posting he's
helping him pick him up that hand in the
back helps him
control him and move around it looks
like a small thing but it's a huge thing
he's definitely holding all of that
weight
but it's easier because he has three
points of carrying the weight which
makes everything easier for everyone it
helps everyone and it's actually
safer
[Applause]
he took the safest bump out of the ring
that you could possibly take and bump
just means when he falls kind of hooked
the top rope to kill the momentum and
just kind of spun out of it from a
beginner's standpoint this is all
very very good it was definitely the
more 80s style maybe even 70s again
because you have the fans so close to
the ring but between the move the
execution the selling the posting
everything about this to me
is real this is a 10 out of 10 for me
take the chain off hey
[Applause]
you're going nowhere
i got you for three minutes so
this is awesome the cage itself those
bars look pretty thick
and pretty flimsy it felt more like
thunderdome than a cage match typically
we use a cage match for
bigger stories it's kind of like the
last big battle a long rivalry between
two talents so that's a pretty big deal
and usually it wouldn't be your first
match
and
three minutes for pro wrestling if you
put a cage down and you only go three
minutes
yeah you might have a riot from the
crowd the actual length of a cage match
will vary i would say
no less than 15 minutes just because
it's usually the main event of whatever
event it is
[Applause]
if you had asked me this maybe when this
movie was made i would say spider-man
moves are pretty unrealistic but then i
have to point out guys like ricochet who
can literally do anything that you've
seen in this clip this day and age i
can't say they're unrealistic
he knows how to get the chair shot in
this clip macho man plays bone saw macho
man randy savage is
one of the greatest professional
wrestlers slash sports entertainers
of all time during the 80s and early 90s
there was no one bigger this is great
work for macho man
[Applause]
what we don't do is we don't take
objects from the crowd to hit each other
with that's a big no-no you start
passing stuff into the ring well you're
probably going to get ejected if it were
a manager or valet or partner that's a
completely different story but generally
we're not just going to take a random
object from the crowd i have seen guys
take food from the crowd though like if
you got a bag of popcorn or a drink i've
seen guys grab that and throw in each
other's face
i'm gonna give this one an eight
kia fans know her as awesome kong she's
actually a
very very very famous pro wrestler she
had a small stint in wwe in japan she's
legend but you can totally see she knows
pro wrestling
they're doing a great job they're really
taking their time and doing actual
wrestling moves so move wise
yes they are spot on with the move
they're definitely slowing down for the
actresses because a lot of those moves
it happens a lot faster i don't have a
problem with that because again
they're doing a show we get to the
actual wrestling i actually think
compared to the actual glow that i
watched as a kid they're pretty toned
down in my opinion because
glow was wild
[Applause]
i like this character working between
moves and showmanship these are all
things that pro wrestlers actually do i
feel like there's an art to catch phrase
the undertaker had rest in peace it's a
way to connect with the fans and the
best thing is when they start doing it
back at you there's nothing better you
know you're doing the right thing when
the fans start mimicking you the ring
looks real the moves look real the
character work is great everything about
this really does remind me of glow that
i used to watch as a kid i would sit up
and watch glow every saturday night i'm
giving it a 10 out of 10. they didn't
turn out the way that i had envisioned
i'm getting more of a chicken vibe
on the amateur level yeah people
definitely decide what their characters
are what their attire is what their
shtick is we call it ring gear on any
given night i've always picked my own
ring gear i think he's so tall
stop throwing snakes
you're just gonna throw sand in my eyes
so i'm gonna run away very over the top
the setting of this is definitely of a
small indie company you might be prone
to see guys who are less experienced on
indie scenes i've seen it where guys are
just way too into their characters and
go way over the top
and
they basically take off the other
performers to some of them just
refuse to work with them i mean you will
see just like
the one guy
i think if i get in the ring gonna throw
salt in my face so i'm just gonna leave
so i mean guys have walked out on
matches before as funny as this is
there's a lot of accuracy in it i'm
gonna say a six
geez
that looked more like
bane breaking batman's back some dark
knight stuff
that back breaker she gave that's
definitely
not a pro wrestling style back breaker
the difference is there's no way to
protect the guy from that she dropped
them right on her knee in the small of
his back if it were done you actually
would break someone's back so when i
bring a guy down i don't want to bring
him down on the small of your back
because i don't want you to bend what i
want to do is maneuver you closer to
across your shoulders between the
shoulder blades so there's no pressure
on your back
the way she came i would even call it a
torpedo dropkick because it looked like
she jumped off of something and just
plowed the crazy thing is that is
exactly what it feels like when someone
gives you a drop kick particularly off
the top rope i've seen guys running and
do it but not with that kind of velocity
but you really are
getting basically kicked in the chest
and there is no way to take that now my
professional opinion okay i would say
sell it more you're right back up man
what are you superman but the actual
drop kick itself that'd look really
legit i would give the back breaker a
three
and i would give the drop kick a 10.
they're just drilling
this base drilling
i was a collegiate wrestler there are
little things that i can tell as an
actor they don't know little things like
once you get into a guy's leg you know
popping your head up so that you can go
around them because if you're looking
down you're easy to take down it's like
the body follows the head so i don't
keep my head down every amateur wrestler
knows this and it makes it easier to go
around just a little thing i feel like i
would defend them rather easily because
his head keeps going down but it looks
very accurate with wwe when we lock up
we don't put our heads down because
again we're performing if we lock up if
we both put our head down well we can't
see each other in a lot of cases you get
accidental head butts
this is turned out sparring they did a
great job of depicting how schultz moved
his mannerisms the intensity of having
hand fights your hands are your defense
some people might say first line of
defense some people might say second
line it kind of varies with who i'm
wrestling they're actually doing a very
good job of depicting the style schultz
would wrestle because if you're watching
this tapes his arms are always kind of
like t-rexy when i wrestled my hands
were forward because i wanted to catch
everything i feel like what they're
doing is kind of a russian style because
it looks very relaxed one of my
teammates was a russian he actually
fought in ufc a few times vladimir
marioshenko and when he arrested me he
had the same t-rexy style arms like some
people you grab when they get stiff and
everything but vladimir when i would
grab him he would stay relaxed and that
messed with me because my thinking is if
someone grabs you your first reaction is
to pull away but he did nothing and it
was kind of like okay what do you do
with this so i think they're depicting
what dave schultz does not necessarily
what an amateur wrestler does or your
typical amateur wrestler would do
wow
he did a little spin move that i've only
ever seen one person do
in college and that guy was me i've
never ever seen anyone do the standing
spin drop into a double leg i'm the only
guy that i knew ever did that
i think every amateur wrestler should
watch this movie this is definitely a
10. favorite wrestling movie i'll be
honest i'm kind of a fan of nacho libre
i like the silliness the tombstone it
looked really convincing yet really safe
if you enjoyed this video please click
above